sur ces images la police ukrainienne
tente de neutraliser un drone volant
tabac saltitude Kiev a été touché par
plusieurs engins Camille caisse de ce
type mais aussi par des missiles
viser des sites énergétiques ce qui a
provoqué des coupures d'électricité un
immeuble résidentiel a aussi été touché
plusieurs morts sont à déplorer en dépit
du danger la vie suit son cours
j'ai vu au moins deux missiles
la semaine dernière aussi j'étais dans
le centre et j'ai vu des missiles voler
non je n'ai pas peur du tout c'est à
Poutine d'avoir peur
l'Ukraine réclame une nouvelle fois plus
d'armes aux occidentaux pour soutenir sa
défense entière aérienne celle-ci a
toutefois été performante ce lundi selon
le porte-parole de l'armée de l'air
selon notre décompte préliminaire de 85
à 96% de ces drones ont été détruits par
notre défense aérienne et nos autres
forces de défense incluant notre au sol
sur ce débris de drones lancé par la
Russie sur Kiev deux mots pour Belgorod
du nom d'une région russe frappée par
l'Ukraine ces derniers jours la Russie
affirme que toutes ces cibles ont été
atteintes ce lundi pas de quoi briser
les Ukrainiens selon les mots du
président Zelinski celui-ci appelle en
revanche la population à limiter sa
consommation d'énergie
à cause de la campagne de terreur de la
Russie dans certaines villes et régions
d'Ukraine il est nécessaire de limiter
l'approvisionnement en électricité pour
permettre à l'ensemble du réseau de
fonctionner
volodimeersky appelle par ailleurs à
exclure la Russie du G20 après les
frappes de ce lundi
et